you know what I sent you guys was
probably maybe one tenth of the oh
really the craziness that is my life
um
you know pretty much even going starting
at the beginning but
um
I guess that all prepares you
know yeah I mean you know it's
interesting I've talked to so many
people who have been through horrific
stuff
like the worst stuff you can imagine and
you ask them like what do you wish was
different about your life or looking
back you know do you wish this hadn't
happened they all say no
it made me who I am
and they're and they're they're fine
with it
it's hard to believe some of those
answers you know I if you ask me that
question
I would I I would trade a lot of it in I
would I'd say no I wouldn't have who
would want to go through that right no
no take it away if you can
um let that cut pass for me God please
um
and that's human I mean
I think it kind of just depends on
how much you've been through
and sometimes
just a few things is enough maybe one
thing is enough
for other people
I don't know I don't know if it's their
Spirit that's uh
either already molded or shaped in a
good way to where they don't need to
learn very much from this life and
others that maybe like myself have to be
continuously challenged for some reason
I don't know the plan I just know that
uh
I have when the ball is put in my court
I have two options
and it's either
let let the trial bear you in the ground
and stay there and lay in the proverbial
uh you know sit in your [__] moment and
stay there or
come to a place of uh acceptance
and and begin the challenging
route
out of the pit
and that's really what it comes down to
tell me about your childhood you grew up
where
I grew up in Wilmington Wilmington
California and what was your family like
uh family was
pretty
pretty crazy uh I learned later right in
the beginning it just all seemed normal
like everybody's existence but then I
started to realize oh people don't beat
each other and uh people aren't running
from gangs all the time and uh people
like hearing gunshots at night is not a
normal thing like oh dead bodies in the
alley that's not normal
um yeah eventually you figure out wow
that was
awful but you didn't feel like that when
you're a kid because it's just normal is
your normal yeah
my whole walk has been laced with just
challenge after challenge after
challenge I mean even starting with like
the birth you know where'd Your Story
start
I mean we could start at sort of the
tail end which is what I emailed you
guys
but uh
I mean my mom was 14 years old when she
had my sister
16 when she had me
17 or 18 when she had my brother and
then my dad left
so I Pro I feel pretty fortunate that
you know she didn't give us up for
adoption or anything she was
a kid herself I think of it now I'm like
you're a kid like how do you how do you
you don't even know what you don't even
know how do you raise kids this is crazy
but she stuck it out you know and uh I
watched her go through her whole
challenge her her whole her whole growth
you know where she she was drinking and
you know even even her story is crazy
you know she's molested by her father
you know was in all kinds of weird head
space and you know
there's some things that happen because
of that she's being bipolar and all this
traumatic stuff so she was
she was pretty messed up but she did the
best she could but that led to just like
I was talking with Noel there's um
everybody gets their programming and for
her it was an awful awful programming
and
uh then that kind of comes down the line
and so there's this this chain effect
and
you know for her it was like it wasn't
so bad to beat the crap out of us
because it was like well I'm not doing
what my dad did to me this is like you
guys don't even know how good you guys
have it you know kind of thing
um
and thankfully she grew a lot a lot I
mean
she's definitely done a win at 180 and
it's different now but
that's probably the first thing I mean
what were you like in high school as a
kid uh High School
you know growing up in Wilmington
there's a it's it's a it was a really
bad area I mean really ghetto
um
gangs constantly you know even in
Wilmington it's the kind of the
stupidest thing you've got you know the
East Side the north side the you know
the west side you know all these
different you know gang you know L
Street and all this other stuff and and
I'm like I laugh because it's like you
guys are we're all within like three
miles of each other come from the same
place but you want to fight and shoot
each other not crazy but you know just
even in middle school I mean I remember
getting jumped so many times because I
didn't want to be part of these gangs
you know and um
my mom always told me just pick one just
pick one you know let that one really
have it you know like
um make sure he remembers you and
yeah it was challenging
um trying to get through there I think
Sports saved me
sports for sure just always trying to be
involved in sports
but man I remember running from from uh
I'll take I would take on two or three
but then when it became four or five I
mean I just knew I didn't want to get
trashed again like that you know so I
remember one time I was running
it was Middle School I was like 12 or
13. and some van you know just opened up
its door and I'm just running they see
all the people running behind me they
opened up the doors beside me kind of
driving and they let me hop in and I was
like oh my God thank you guys so much
and they're like yeah you know are you
okay and like you know you're blood in
your face and stuff because I mean I I
did as much as I could and after that I
was like you know this is a losing
battle I gotta get out of here
um
but yeah that was that was tough that
was a tough upbringing you know
I was glad to get out of there and
um at a certain point I got in a lot of
trouble
my mom was like you know you gotta go
live with your dad which was funny to me
because I didn't even know she was
talking to my dad I had no interaction
with my dad very little and I'm like you
know where my dad lives she's like yeah
you're gonna go live with your dad I
just can't you know can't deal with you
kind of thing not because if I was bad
in school like grades and stuff but just
the extracurricular stuff and
fights and things like that
and when I went to go live with them my
dad and his his girlfriend at the time
it was crazy because I saw a different
world
and I realized at the time
wow this is like a completely different
world like
you know the people are different how
they speak is different how they talk
and how they carry themselves it's just
different I saw a guy who was wearing
something that looked like he was in a
gang and I kind of went up to him and I
was just like like where are you from or
whatever he's like what are you talking
about and I'm like
yeah you're dressed like a gang member
he's like oh no this is like a style I
was like
what it was weird it was super weird and
I I just I was like a style dang this is
crazy this is
I mean you wouldn't think it's four
hours away right Central Coast San Luis
San Luis Obispo County
um Oreo Grande up there
um
but yeah that was a
that was me and pretty much High School
bouncing around going back and forth but
at least I got to experience a different
a different place so that gave me a lot
of perspective
um
I think after uh
high school things got kind of tough
my mom ended up you know in and out of
relationships they were bad right she
didn't know when you're somebody who
is treated the way she was as a kid you
don't know how to love you never really
learn what real love is
um
you just
so you you have a bad meter you pick bad
Partners you don't even know she was in
abusive relationships I seen that when I
was a kid her always getting beat on
them trying to beat on me her beating me
up had my nose broken several times you
know
um
it was crazy
she would I mean the standing on
standing on a wall putting your nose to
the wall with your arms up for hours
while she fell asleep you know
um
and it's like that's okay you're like
hitting you with a stick or whatever's
close you know and uh I remember one
time there was like a nail in a piece of
wood that you know like if you're uh
your your window the little latch breaks
you put usually like a p like a stick in
there so someone can't open the window
um and the panel and the pain there so I
remember she grabbed one of those and
she started hitting me with it and there
was a stick with a nail in it she didn't
know I don't think but I'm screaming
bloody murder and there's blood on me
and I'm and eventually she saw it but
then you know she was so crazy at the
time where she was just like oh okay
well don't bleed on my carpet you little
[__] you know kind of thing and I was
like crying my face off you know
um
there's all kinds of moments like that
that
it's funny because I remember she called
me not to
like not too long ago maybe
maybe like a year ago I think and we
hadn't been talking very much but she
called and she said
something along the lines of you know
hey I'm really sorry like I'm
I'm really sorry for all the things that
I did to you and it just wasn't right
and things like that and at that point I
think well let me tell you what I said I
said
it's okay you didn't even know what you
didn't even know
like you had no clue
really what what love was
and your programming was so messed up
that and you were so messed up in your
head in your heart and all your
experiences that you just felt like that
was normal you just that was
that's just normal which is crazy now
you know it's not and now you're calling
me to apologize so I appreciate that you
know and my mom's apologized a lot and
uh and she still does every now and then
which is obviously it's healing it's
good to hear
but I don't even need to hear it anymore
you know it's just that's what she
experienced but
[Music]
um
going back to just my experience in in
Middle School
um
and growing up I think there is a point
where
I didn't know my dad very well but he
was kind of crazy like he he was um
he was like a big kid you know he wasn't
the kind of guy that like
he really gave me like something I can
stand on like a foundation like a father
he was just like this big kid he's
always joking and acting kind of dumb
and silly
um
I'd go to work with him a little bit
taught me some things you know as far as
like carpentry and plumbing and stuff
like that and and I remember one time
you know my stepbrother who's about my
age so the lady that he ended up being
with left my mom for he stayed with her
and her son from another marriage was my
age so we're in the same grade so
um we're going to middle school and
everything anyway he himself at one
point gets in trouble because he's
skateboarding he's acting stupid he's
doing things vandalizing he's breaking
Windows you know whatever the cops come
and they dream they bring him to my
where my dad lives and they tell my dad
what happens and literally my dad's
breaking down because the guy says you
know if he gets in one more you know
does anything else he's going a juvenile
hall kind of thing
I was in the room and I kind of
overheard my dad and his
you know his um
fiance or girlfriend long-term
girlfriend talking with him and he's
crying and he's like don't you know I
love you boy and stuff like that and
like in my head I'm thinking like
I I was I don't know if I was jealous
angry uh conf I was like all kinds of
emotion at that when I heard that
um because when you're a kid with
growing up without a dad you think to
yourself
like
the hell like where's that for me like
kind of [__] is this all right this is
weird
um
there's a there's a time where
I was supposed to go to school in maybe
a couple weeks and I was telling my Dad
hey Dad can you know look at my shoe
there's like a freaking like the shoes
talking you know like I need I need
shoes and I feel embarrassed I can't go
to school with a shoe that's freaking
flapping like this is ridiculous
and he's like tell your mom you know
your mom tell her to send you some money
so call my mama mama needs some shoes
hey you're with your dad now tell him to
buy you some shoes
really go back to my dad mom said but
you know he's like no you know she
eventually she's gonna get you I'm a
[__]
so then you know I'm like you know what
these they're both gonna argue about it
I need shoes so
you know a lot of Rebel came out in me
most of the time because I was always
just curious and
I didn't feel supported or loved so I'm
like whatever I'm gonna do some some I'm
gonna steal some shoes in right
um and so then I went to a Foot Locker
and at the time was a standalone
building
and I remember the guy gave me like a
size 11 shoe
and or like 10 and a half I think it was
at the time yeah so anyway I told him it
was too big and if you can go get
another size so as soon as you turn the
corner to go back I ran out the store
left the old shoes there ran out with
the new shoes
this guy was pretty fast
[Laughter]
he was like a younger guy
um but I mean I was lightning at that
time I mean plus I was at all adrenaline
and you know I did run track in school
so I was gone there's I mean I didn't
feel like my feet were touching the
ground I was just gone
and um
I remember I thought I got away with it
maybe a couple weeks later I'm with uh
one of my friends this guy uh Chris also
another Chris
and we're playing basketball we always
played basketball I mean I go to his
house knock on his you know screen door
and tell me hey he's Chris here and I
remember his mom was super racist a lot
of people there were it was crazy I I
knew there was a lot of racism but I
experienced it pretty hardcore at this
point in my life
um
where
she was just like you know she she
basically called me the n-word and like
I was and and my friend's like Mom you
know like what's wrong with you
and he's not even black you know like
and I was like yeah I'm not even black
like what the hell and she didn't care
she's like if you ain't white you ain't
right you know
um so
I just remember we go play basketball we
ended up at another friend's house at
this you know that's that same day and
his mom was super racist also
and so we're in the she didn't want to
let me in the house and so we're sitting
there he basically argues with with his
mom this other kid and eventually we're
inside his room playing you know PS2 at
the time
just playing some PS2 and then all of a
sudden on the door you know and then
he's like Mom leave us alone you know
and I'm like
and then you we're all like looking at
each other and you hear open the door
there's the police you know like oh [__]
so we're like oh I'm going to open the
door and a police officer comes in
and he's just like he points at me he
has his flashlight and he's like you
outside I'm like the hell did I do you
know like
so I go outside and you know he starts
you know putting my Hammerhead put my
hand back he arrested me literally put
handcuffs on me sat me on the floor
he's like do you know why we arrested
you and I'm like no
he's like
well this this woman says that you took
her earrings at the time I had like you
know cubic zirconia earrings in I mean
these are like the five dollar earrings
you can go to the mall and buy
and I'm like these are like five dollars
from them like what are you talking
about like we've been in his room the
whole time and even his friends yelling
at his mom like Mom you called the
police on my friend and blah blah and
he's yelling at her she's trying to yell
at the police officer like he stole my
arm like no I didn't it was crazy
then
one of the other officers come up and
it's because you know it's a small town
so I mean you don't get away with [__]
there I mean these guys are like white
on rice so they come out
and they're like when he walks up and he
looks at me
and then he puts his flashlight and he
looks down at my shoes and I was like I
like instantly knew I was like oh [__]
this guy knows like and he gets on his
leg when he starts talking on his thing
he talks about the red shoes you know
and I was like [__]
you know and then he's you know it comes
back yeah it's another Hispanic Mill
blah blah like damn he goes he's like
yeah nice shoes
you steal those and I was like I
couldn't even lie at that point I mean
they caught me you know they was like
what was I gonna say no you know like I
had to just be like [__] yeah he's like
all right now you're going to juvenile
hall he took my shoes off put him in a
bag and like took me in the car
when they when I went to juvenile hall
it sucked because I mean first of all
it's cold as [__] and I never been in
trouble so it was just something that I
mean
you're sitting on a cold bed and
they give you like these cut off
Converse shoes and it's just there's no
pillow there's no blanket it sucked and
I asked the guy there I said like
um so what's going to happen he's like
well I don't know your your parents have
to come get you and I'm like
okay so where's my dad he's like I don't
know he could have picked you up like
today he could pick you up today and so
I'm like do I get to call him or
whatever he's like yeah you can call I
called nobody answered several times I
get to call nobody answered
so then three days go by and he finally
picks me up
and by this point I'm sour [__] I was so
sour I was so angry
and and I remember getting in the car
and I was like
like why like how come you didn't pick
me up and he's just like oh you learned
your lesson
and I was like I was so pissed I mean I
was always whippy so I was just like now
you want to be a dad
I was so pissed and he looked at me oh
he got when I said that I mean like a
fire bursted in his eyeballs he was just
like and I was he was like he was oh
there was a fire that I had never seen
in his face
but anyway that's that was kind of
shitty right that was the
that's kind of my experience with my
parents they didn't know how to handle
me and I felt like at a certain point I
knew more than them I was smarter than
them I always read I was in magnet
programs
um it was always easy for me to get good
grades in school I had a photographic
memory I'd sit in the front and just
listen and I always I never had to study
my sister hated me even though she went
to Berkeley and USC and eventually
became a professor but she always she
was always jealous of like my ability to
just not have to study or do anything
and get Easy A's
um
later on she basically said you know
I want to have a relationship you I just
I just always felt that you know mom
showed me so much favoritism that you
kind of hated me for it because she did
my mom was pretty much living
vicariously through my sister and
everything that she didn't get
she was trying to make right she was
trying to correct through my sister my
older sister
um
but either way high school I remember
that's what that was kind of the normal
thing going back and forth with my dad
and then even at some point I was living
with a friend even going to school I was
living with a friend because I didn't
want to live with either of them I felt
like both of them were still kind of
working through their [__] and I was
like you know what
it can't be with either other either of
you guys and at one point I remember
my mom
had a boyfriend cheated on her they had
a house they sold it in Long Beach and
she moved in with some other guy
when I couldn't be where my dad was I
came back and it was High School
and
um I was living with them and this guy
and this guy was just such an ass he was
such a terrible human being like but my
mom again she picks all the winners
right
um and so
I was going to school I graduated and I
was I literally applied for what I can
get to go to a community college right
there at El Camino in Torrance and I
paid for my books I paid for everything
they didn't have to do anything and my
mom even said I don't have money I'm
sorry kid because they're paying for my
sister to go to Berkeley at the time
which is super expensive and she barely
could keep up with the curriculum and
you know
it is what it is kid sorry you know hey
what are we gonna do you know so I
Community you know Community College was
was the ticket and I'm like okay I'm
gonna go there I'm gonna pay for it I'm
working
and then at one point her husband or her
boyfriend excuse me
he goes
he's like all right I'm gonna need you
to pay me some rent
I'm like
did you talk to my mom about this she
he's like yeah I already talked to your
mom about this I mean you can't be you
know you're using the water electricity
eating all the food and yeah I'm like
but so is everybody else you know like
what about your two sons living here and
your daughter there was like his three
kids living there all of them which were
older than me none of them paying rent
I was like this is crazy and I remember
having a talk with my mom like in the
garage I'm like Mom like she caught me
washing some clothes she's like did you
talk to him about washing clothes and
I'm like yeah he said that I'm soaking
up the water and the electricity that he
wants me to give him like 400 bucks a
month uh for rent a month I'm like you
know I can't do that she's like well you
have a job don't you and I'm like Mom
you're really gonna make me pay this guy
rent like it's not my fault you sold
your house lived here you know I'm
paying for school I'm working and you
want me to pay rent like this crazy
I rather live in my car
so I did
I had a the first car I ever bought by
myself it was a VW bus
and uh it was an orange one uh with like
the tan top little surfer surfer bus
right
um it was cold as [__] in there I could
tell you that much
um
you know having to go to work go to
school live in this van I parked it in
front of my grandma's house
I guess hoping I was gonna get some
sympathy eventually I remember sleeping
in that thing and my grandma like knocks
on the door and I opened it up she's
like miho
you can come inside this is after like
two weeks of me living in this car you
know and um I guess my mom called her up
out of anger and told her not to let me
stay there you know and my grandma
wasn't gonna not listen to my mom
but anyway I mean there's just all kinds
of random stuff like that
I had a I had a daughter in 2015 and
at the time
everything was going well I was married
working
um
you know I thought life was I thought
this was like okay I'm gonna this is
life right
again then I have my son which I felt so
blessed because I was thinking you know
boy a girl now I got a boy like you know
that was a big thing to me especially
when it comes to my son because there
was a lot of wrongs that happened in my
life that I would like to have righted
and um
uh he he had a couple of issues
um when it came to his his ureters
um when it comes to being able to to pee
there was a little bit of a reflux
happening because he started getting
um infections so we took him in a couple
times the urologist was like hey
I think his ureters are a little
torturous and that's causing some type
of reflux so I think you know he'll grow
out of it eventually they'll kind of
straighten out it's kind of a fluke they
did all kinds of testing and they said
it's not genetic there's no there's
nothing we can really point to it's
something that's not very common at all
but typically kids just grow out of it
as they stretch and grow everything
should be fine it should resolve itself
at one point another guy came in there
another doctor and he said you know what
I think it would be best if we did a
little bit of a surgery and shortened
them up so we didn't have to because he
kept getting infections because there
was a little catheter in there and so
when you have a foreign object that
causes infection so he said you know
this might be a better solution until he
he grows it's a very it's mentally
invasive you know
P will just come out his diaper we'll
kind of hook his tubes up here to his
skin and it'll just come out naturally
and uh you know I will reattach them
later and it's like an hour surgery kind
of thing
so he has that done he goes through
their flying colors no issues doctor
says hey everything went great
um
and then
I was there you're not allowed to have
any any kid under two years old in the
picu or um and you know in that ICU
there so I ended up taking my daughter
so that you know I could
you know feed her take you know put her
to bed and my my wife at the time stayed
with our son
um overnight and I had to work in the
morning so I said okay I'll take her
home I'll do everything and then I'll
come back
and you can have her and then you could
you know sort of will
swap it out here and I can go to work
um
and then uh
I was working and then I
at the time I was uh putting these
little flyers I was doing the sales job
on on homes and then I got back to my
car and I don't know why I had left my
phone like in my car I was just gonna
hit this like little block here and then
come back to my car I get back to my car
and there's like 15 missed calls
um you know from all these from my my
brother-in-law my sister my mom my you
know my wife so I call my wife and she's
just like get to the hospital now
um something's wrong with with Liam
uh and I just got I was like oh [__] so
I jump in the car and I mean I'm I'm
flying on the 405 like
not even in Lanes like I'm going to the
I'm however I can get there so I get
there
and they're pumping on his chest
um you know they're they're trying to
revive him
um
I go in there and
you know the doctor is just like
you know we we've we've done this longer
than we should have
um
I think I think it's time to call it but
you know I'm letting you know
um you know we can we can continue if
you want to and I said I don't care how
long it takes just just whatever you
need to do just keep keep trying and
he's like okay well then you you can do
the chest compressions and then we're
gonna have you know and
and so I did that for a time you know
they injected him with a lot of other
things they tried different you know
different things and you know his lungs
had collapsed
um
they try to you know stick a tube in
there and um
it was just awful it was it was awful to
see
such a terrible turn of events where it
was all everything was fine it was
you know he's a
nearly 15 pound four-month-old baby you
know
um
and
you know and then all of a sudden
you know he's just kind of twitching and
then I'm thinking you know well no he's
still moving and the doctor is saying no
that's just some type of uh nerve
reaction and
and my my wife is just freaking out and
you know there's so many people huddled
around him and uh
yeah I was really messed up
I I didn't think I never thought I'd
have to experience something like that
in life and uh what was the cause
ultimately there was a nurse who
forgot to log all the medications she
gave him
and I guess she had some issue with her
boyfriend or something like that and she
was in distress and forgot to log it the
next nurse came back in and gave him
another dose of meperidine Benadryl and
morphine and they overdosed him they
suppressed his breathing his lungs
collapsed and they couldn't bring him
back he was suffocating slowly
and over medicated for many hours
before you know he finally gave out and
they couldn't bring him back
and so
uh
I remember the urologist came in there
and he's like I don't know what happened
Chris I he was fine when I left him last
night
um
he's like I don't know what happened but
we need to get to the bottom of this you
know and they kept trying to
say that you know he was a sick baby and
you know he's in a better place and you
know even the nurse tried to have me one
of the head nurse tried to have me sign
this paperwork and whatnot and I was
like I'm not signing that [__] like what
are you doing like I'm trying to you
know it was it was awful just to see
your baby just lifeless and and my wife
at the time just did not want to leave
him she just kept holding him even
though he was just getting stiff and
um
I I couldn't even I I at the time I
it's like everything turns black and
white
and you just
you feel like it's just like a nightmare
you want to wake up from but you can't
like you're trying and you're hoping
that you when you go to sleep at night
that you wake up and it's not real that
it was just
some [__] up dream but it was real
and
you know
there's a lot of stuff that happened
after that
[Music]
um
I tried to keep it together because I
knew that something
what was something wasn't right they
didn't do something right I had to try
to get to the bottom of it my wife at
the time was just
she was not even functioning at all
and and I did my best to be the strong
one to be like okay well what can we do
they're like we'll do the autopsy and
stuff like that I'm like no
No don't touch him you know
um
we went and hired a independent forensic
path a pathologist to do the uh
um a quantitative analysis on his blood
and all this other stuff you know
um and they made it tough they made it
tough to get his body they made it tough
to do a lot of things and so that just
gave me more fire like okay there has to
be something that they did wrong because
clearly they wouldn't be giving me this
much pushback on everything
um
and so
long story short with that sadly you
know although we did do something and we
got a little something it was uh you
know medical malpractice in California
they passed the law in the 70s where you
can only get 250. that's the max
and um
I guess when you have hospitals and
insurance companies and all these big
wigs that are going to be able to push
their way around there they'll find a
way because
that's what they do you know so it it it
didn't really help no no amount of money
would have ever helped anyway but
um
you know just having to get his damn
headstone and
it was awful and my wife at the time she
really went nuts like she
like being a Christian is a big thing to
us like we were
we have always been very Christian and
you know she was even praying for him to
be raised from the dead like Lazarus and
um I was trying in my own way to
to walk the fine line of like hey
we we have to accept that he's gone you
know he
and she's just like no no like you know
she's like you don't believe with me and
she was just like
she really
she really kind of tried to make it like
I was not on her side
and I just wanted her to be okay and I
knew that the way she was going wasn't
right and I
this went on for a long time even to the
point where
you know they were fixing him up and
preparing him for burial and she still
was praying that to be to happen
and
um
I know sometimes the answer is no
sometimes the answer is no
and um
so
I think the big thing there was um
you know she
kept praying that we buried him and even
after he was buried she was still she
couldn't she couldn't let it go she
couldn't come to terms with what had
happened
um she started
reaching out to like really and doing
really weird stuff like you know
uh tarot cards and and crystals and
trying to do this remote writing stuff
where she felt like she can communicate
with him from the dead and
um I mean the weird thing about that is
there's [__] flying off the walls like
at night I mean I feel like she was
letting something weird in from what she
was doing it was it was very very odd
um
I won't speculate there I just know
there was weird [__] happening and it
felt like there was something heavy and
evil
um that was messing with her
um and uh
you know I there's a point where
I thought she was getting better because
she started going to church you know she
I think at a certain point I saw
something a little something different
and I I I kind of got happy about it
I was like oh okay like you know
um you know this is maybe like a year
into it you know
um
she starts going to this church
everything's you know starts um helping
out and it was one day a week then it
was two days and it was three then it
was five days and it was like she's
there every day
and um and I was working and she she was
going to church and I felt okay maybe
things are getting better
and then I started noticing
um some interaction between her
um and this uh pastor of Prayer
and because I'm so observant and because
like I said I have a photographic memory
I don't know if I have auditory but it's
it's sure hard to forget a face or
anything I've read or heard or anything
and it's all in recall
and so I noticed things
um and I started noticing little looks
um one time I kind of caught him like
kind of looking at her cleavage and I'm
like
I know he's not just staring at her
chest right now like
and he just did it for an extended
period of time and then he's just and
then I I'm looking at him and then he
looks at me and he's like oh you know
I'm like okay I'm not imagining this
[__] this is okay
and I mean this guy it got to a point
where we were doing some counseling with
him
um praying for our family playing for
some healing and everything then we
started doing some counseling with the
church and then I was talking to this
other guy a lot of and but they were all
older you know this guy was like nearly
60 55 something like that and the other
guy was even older he's about you know
60 65.
um that was counseling me also and I
started telling him like I'm feeling
uncomfortable with
you know with this man like now my
wife's part of this prayer team and
she's always at the church and now she's
doing social media and she's doing all
this other stuff
and I'm thinking like
um
I don't know there's something weird
then I I one time her laptop was open
and I kind of just was walking by the
table and I I saw you know his name on
an email
um and so I probably shouldn't have done
that but I clicked on it and I you know
she was in the shower and I just see
that the way they spoke and it was very
flirty and there's like you know uh like
a heart emoji and like you know just
stuff like that and I was like
okay this is this is this some some's up
here this ain't right
um and then I had this talk with the
pastor
um or with the counselor guy about it
and I said he's making me uncomfortable
and I think I feel like there's
something weird going on he's like well
he's like come on Chris this guy's old
enough to be your guys's dad you know I
think you're just being a little uh
paranoid about this and come on you know
and
eventually it came to a head maybe about
a month later where
I just kept noticing things and the way
she was defending him and just there's
just some things that she was saying I
was catching every little bit
um and eventually
it came to a head where they had a
meeting with us and and they were told
not to have any interaction
because I was uncomfortable and they
were trying to push me to get counseling
and all this stuff
um and so they were told to have no
interaction then she goes a couple days
later I'm gonna go
um get a bottle of wine from one of my
friends you know it's her birthday or
blah blah I'm like okay
I took my daughter to Roger Dunn we're
sitting there putting a little bit you
know
um and as I pulled out Roger Dunn
I was going by this one Winery place
like a wine total wine or something like
that
and I lit I it blew my freaking mind I
literally looked to the left and I see
him and her standing
like holding each other's hands
like staring into each other's faces
like
out I like turned the car so hard and
I've just drove right next to him and I
stopped I jumped out of the car
and he tried to hide from me he tried to
go behind another car and run
um and I caught him right and I'm like
oh so pissed I mean
I was like you [__] I was so mad
I
I wanted to kill him
I really wanted to kill him because
there that that was that's all I needed
to see
that's all I needed to see to know
and you know he was trying to run for me
and he's trying to grab me and I'm
trying to grab him and and then he's
just like nothing happened and nothing
happened and I'm like [__] guilty
people don't run you [__] her like I was
so I wanted to kill him but then
um and even even her at the time like
she was just like leave him alone and I
was just like she's like I'm gonna call
the police you know and I couldn't
believe it I was like you're gonna
you're gonna call the police on your
husband on your husband like
oh what's this oh I mean the the the the
level of anger
and betrayal
um
oh man it sucked it was awful
and
and thank God that I had a very sobering
thought at that moment through all that
heightened just craziness your
daughter's in the car
she saved me
my daughter saved me because I knew she
was in the car
and I was like you know what
I was like you better sit on I I I told
him you better sit on the floor right
now like he listened to me because he
saw how pissed I could have killed him
um and I told her take our daughter and
get out of here
she took our daughter and she drove away
I called that head Pastor he didn't
answer I said you're gonna call him
right now
and he picks up his phone he calls he
put it on speaker he answers and the guy
answers the phone and I was like
this is you know me and his guy right
I'm like
guess what I just found this [__]
with my wife he was you were told to
have no interaction like in blah blah
and he goes oh my God I'm so sorry Chris
I'm so sorry
and and eventually I had another meeting
the next day with the guy who'd been
counseling me
and he confirmed everything and this guy
confessed everything and said you know
what they were doing
and it was awful another moment where
everything just went I mean I I didn't
want to believe it
as smart as I am I had I in all the
lodge I'm very logical but my heart
didn't want to accept it I didn't want
to believe it how many years was this
after losing your son two
you think they're related
of course because later on she tried to
say you know
you know I'm going to sue the church and
you know he brainwashed me and he
groomed me and all this other stuff and
then I'm like I don't care
I I
you cross the line there's no there's no
there's no coming back from I just can't
there's nothing I could do here this is
the the the level of pain that I felt in
my heart like I I felt like there was a
vice squeezing the [__] out of my heart
and I just
when that Pastor confirmed it or the
other the other
um and the counselor that told him that
told me that I'm sitting there and I
just everything went black and white
again and I was like oh my God like what
it what the [__] like this
this isn't uh
this is not even like the worst movie
you can invent like this is crazy
and I just went home and I cried and I
cried and I cried and my heart just hurt
so bad I just I was on the floor just
saying just take me now God like just I
can't even live in this world like this
is this is psycho who would
who could endure this
who can endure this much hurt as much
pain this much betrayal this much like
after I just lost my son like how who
could I just
and and I just and I stayed there I
stayed there on the ground
for weeks
weeks just disappearing you know just a
loss probably like 50 60 pounds I I
you know didn't even want to get up to
go the bathroom I'd you know
I just
and again
after so much hurt and pain people
calling me
people coming over knocking on the door
asking if I'm okay I just I didn't
answer didn't answer phone died I just I
just I battled and I wrestled with
wanting to live
and the only thing I could think was you
know
um
you still have one
you may have lost everything you lost
your son you lost your wife but you
still have your daughter
and she deserves a dad
you got to get up
you can't just lay here no more you got
it you gotta get up
and I prayed and I prayed I kept telling
God like what do I do God what can I
how do I overcome this how
first I was just pissed I was so angry
like like why would you do this to me
God like why would you let me go through
all this
like what did I do what did I do I've
done nothing what did I do
and you start wrestling with God and you
start you know thinking that God's doing
it to you
[Music]
um
I've learned a lot in my time
and I've had to overcome a lot and I've
had to grow a lot
and I've had to
learn a lot of
coping mechanisms and strategies to to
come back from all that
and
now I know
hey I have a daughter all right so that
helped me
but B there's a lot of other people that
have been through this kind of stuff
I'm not alone
there's people that have been through
more
and even if somebody's been through less
but they feel like it's similar
um
they need help too
and so even in the darkest time
I always heard God
I always felt like he was there
and I always felt
him safe like one simple thing which is
help others
just help others
so I started to accept that you know
maybe I'm going through all this so that
I can
know what it's like
to be lost
to be
just
so destroyed just
have no hope
feel like you don't want to live
feel like there's no purpose feel like
there's just chaos and nothing matters
um and going through all that that made
me
start to understand that okay maybe
if I can come back from this
um
everyone can
and so
there's a lot more but you know we don't
have a whole lot of time here
but I think the big thing is um
there's
there's always a plan and there's always
a purpose
and
you could either use it or let it
destroy you
and I choose to use it
so your family now is tell me about that
yeah so
it's really it's one of those things
where
nobody likes to go through these trials
these challenges just these terrible
moments in life and
when you're going through them you
always feel like no one will ever know
how I feel right now like this I'm so
alone
I'm like this is just like I must be
going through the worst thing in the
history of civilization but in
retrospect after I went through
everything I went through
I realized it was for a purpose
um and I never imagined it would be for
pretty much the same thing that you know
when it comes to my brother
um
so my brother
sadly you know he
he was leaving a park he went and played
with his kids he was he's such a great
dad he's always toting him around in his
left and right arm you know his two
four-year-olds and he's leaving a park
and he's on right here in uh
on piece or excuse me was on the Vermont
headed towards PCH
and some lady just pulled out from a
park position right in front of him
um and it's a highway so people are
going somewhere between 45 55 whatever
it is there and so he swerves to avoid
otherwise he would have T-boned her goes
into oncoming traffic and then has to go
left even further to avoid the oncoming
traffic hits the curb somehow the lady
who described it to us she was there
literally watching it like a movie she
she super traumatized this lady she's
like it just
popped the corner and just started
rolling over and she's like it just it's
like It sped up
and she said it was awful she was
everybody that was there
were they were all freaking out thinking
it was gonna it was gonna explode it hit
it knocked over many trees and ended up
coming to arrest on a light pole one of
those big concrete ones and um
it was on its side and you know he
unfortunately at that point was pinned
underneath the the cab of the truck
um some bystanders all got out of the
cars and a lot of men
you know rolled it over to get him out
um
unfortunately my niece was under there
too
and she she
was dead
her little head got pinched
his son
really messed up also a lot of phones
broken fractures spine broken or
fractured several places
um had his ear ripped out from the seat
belt I mean it was just a terrible
accident
um
and uh
yeah sadly you know they say that you
know he he had some alcohol in his
system and it was a big ordeal and now
it's been two years coming up on the
two-year anniversary and he's still in
jail waiting for the for the trial
because yeah he they say from you know
none of it's proven yet but that's what
they say even though they have these
broken vials and all the stuff that's
what they're relying on which is crazy
but yeah
I'm biased right like so
um
and then obviously why I'm wearing this
shirt
my sister just got diagnosed with cancer
and it's one of those very aggressive
cancers
and now she's um
starting her second round of chemo on
Friday
and you know my mom went over there and
shaved her head because it was just very
traumatic to see all the hair falling
out of your head so my mom
used my clippers to shave her head
and uh
you know so it's fun it's weird it's I
don't want to say it's funny but it's
it's like I feel like everything that
I've gone through has prepared me to
to be that
sort of Beacon of Hope in my family to
to tell them like hey you know you're
you're going through it but you're gonna
get through this
um
you know everybody's got their trial and
I've seen it and I I know what it feels
like to be just
on the floor hurting broken
crying and and whether you're religious
or you don't believe in anything or
you're you know other religions in me or
what have you
um
everybody tends to feel the same they
they're going to get this moment where
they really isolate and they feel alone
like nobody understands and why is this
happening to me and
like
I don't even want to live like how do I
get through this and no matter how much
support they have you know my sister has
three kids she's got a husband
um but the amount of breakdowns I've
seen her have
um
is a blessing to me by the way because
she's barely starting to open up to me
she always thought that I resented her
for for getting all the favoritism you
know and she's just like I'm so thankful
to have you guys in my life like now and
I'm like yeah I've been here the whole
time you know like
um it's kind of sad that cancer had to
be the thing that opened that door for
us to now have this really good
relationship but either way I don't care
I'm here for you
and so we've had a lot of heart to
hearts and
it's kind of like a
you get a lot of time when you're
sitting there plugged in you know to
chemo and having to get all this stuff
flowing through you and
you know four or five hours sitting
there eight hours sitting there and it's
like man we can this is a way better
therapy than what you could pay for
talk about our childhood Cut From the
Same Cloth
um
and then when it comes to my brother
sadly you know sitting in jail
[Music]
um
my poor mother just hearing her cry
about it the other day just
like what can I do for my kids like I
can't do anything for this one I can't
do anything I'm like well hey you got
one I had nothing wrong with me right
now
and she's just like [__] I know at least
I got that right so
I guess I'm kind of just
now understanding
what are all the what all these trials
are for
and and it's really to
bring us closer together
because
it's like being a humans just are not
designed to be alone
we're not designed to be alone like you
you can't argue with that I mean you it
takes
two people to make another another human
you know well before all our science and
everything and what have you but
you need that and and Community is
important
and
having this sort of mirror that can sit
there and listen to you and your issues
your problems your hurts your pains your
struggles everything that you're going
through and then hopefully there's
somebody who really knows you really
understands
can can say hey
you'll get through it
the worst that could happen is you die
but you know what
death has 100 kill rate last time I
checked
we're all gonna die
but while we're going through these
trials it's so important to have support
to have friends to have family to have a
therapist I mean have a dog anything you
need you need more you need more more
help and more people more community
and
sadly when people are going through this
stuff it's it's the weirdest thing it's
kind of uh
I don't want to call it human nature but
it's just the nature of when you're
going through things you want to isolate
and you may not even realize it you just
for whatever reason you just
you know even my sister said I just
don't want you know don't come I don't
want you to see me like this
and I thought
see you like this I mean
[__] if there's any any time you
actually needed somebody it's now I mean
better to see you like drunk you know or
intoxicated or uh you know gorging
yourself on something or like you know
no this is uh
this is the time you need you need me
and I'm here for you
I think in life
everybody's going to go through trials
everybody's going to go through hurt and
pain and whether you're some starving
kid in Africa who's promised a sweet
potato for your birthday and you haven't
eaten for three days and your dad
doesn't bring it and you're just so
disappointed crying in your little
corner of the Hutt
or you're some
affluent you know person in Corona del
Mar where your dad promised you if you
were going to get straight A's they'd
get you the BMW M series with the right
colors that you like and everything and
then you told all your friends and then
on your birthday honk honk it's the
basic model you go cry in your room
just so embarrassed that it's not the
one that you said you were gonna get
those kids they feel the same
on the inside
on the outside we look at it like oh
you're spoiled little [__] and I feel
bad for you you you're not even eating
but everybody's mountain is everybody's
Mountain
and everybody will have one or two or
many
so
it's all about what you do have control
over you don't have control over what
happens to you
um but you do get to decide
how it affects you
that's great and that's your power
It's a Wonderful story
thanks thank you so much Chris
you're doing better now yeah absolutely
good for you that's all I try to do is
just
um
God always takes me to places where I
can try to inspire people try to help
them
let them tell me their story and then
sometimes when they a lot well it's
pretty much every time they hear even a
fraction of mine they're like wow okay
because there's you know when you've
been through it now you have clout
now you have
something to stand on because you've
been through it and that's what it's all
about it's it's uh it's going through it
and growing through it so that you can
be a teacher so that you can be a helper
and so that you can speak with
experience and experiential wisdom
all right thank you very much yep